signée jacques rivette cette fois jeanne
la pucelle sort mercredi sur les grands
écrans une longue fresque de plus de
cinq heures trente en deux parties de
méliès à otto preminger le destin de
jeanne d'arc inspirait une bonne
quarantaine de réalisateur après ingrid
bergman michel morvan ou encore jean
seberg
c'est la marginale de sans toit ni loi
sandrine bonnaire qui incarne jeanne
d'arc ne pucelle pilleuse mais rieuse
colérique et moqueuse tout comme pascal
deschamps il machine et d'un appui soso
claque très impressionné à la fois par
la proposition de jacques rivette
sandrine bonnaire a mesuré les risques
et puis elle a foncé prête à toutes les
comparaisons
ce jour là la 40e jeanne d'arc à l'écran
rencontre est la spécialiste de
l'histoire de jeanne celle là même dont
rivette lui avait demandé de lire les
livres pour préparer le rôle
verdict c'est ce qui pour moi traduit le
plus complètement et le plus simples
mots l'histoire l'histoire vraie cpo
fatigue maximum d'émotions et mougins le
destin de cette toute jeune fille qui
quitte sa famille à 17 ans pour brûler
vive à 19 de cette petite paysanne qui
ébranle l'ordre établi cette subtilité
qui est propre femme
nous déposerons un des arguments
spécieux
pour la rentrée la confusion du tandem
égard et je savais dès le début que vous
étiez mon ami c'est moi je suis pas allé
à l'école très longtemps chez j'ai
commencé ce métier j'avais 15 ans donc
je suis allé à l'école jusqu'en 5e
donc il y avait comme ça une peur d'eux
j'ai toujours eu une peur d'apprendre
les choses et peut-être parce que je me
sentais pas le droit je sais pas
et donc quand jacques m'a donné les
livres je me suis dit ouh là là j'ai
plein de livres à lire ou ça va être y
avoir un côté scolaire et je vais rien y
comprendre cette histoire c'est tout ça
et alors je sais c'est formidable
vous avez réussi vraiment parce que ben
oui parce qu'on le lit comme ça et csc
pour tout le monde c'est pas pour les
intellectuels forcément c'est pas pour
c'est pour n'importe qui pour tout le
monde
exactement comme le film de jacques
rivette comme la jeanne d'arc que
composent sandrine bonnaire en toute
modestie
loin des clichés avec ses défauts ses
qualités loin des récupérations
politiques des uns ou des autres
une jeune femme toute simple porté par
sa foi à faire le sacrifice de sa vie
la musique de ce film jeanne la pucelle
a été composée par ordis aval le chef
d'orchestre espagnol qui interprète à la
viole de gambe la bande son du film tous
les matins du monde